i'm bob sutton i'm an organizational
psychologist i've been at the stanford
engineering school for more than 35
years studied all sorts of elements of
leading innovation how i see myself as
at that sort of uncomfortable
intersection between the rigor of
academia and what it takes to get things
done in the real world
so in leading innovation i'm bringing
you ideas at the intersection between
three things first of all the best
research we could find about what
leaders do to promote innovation things
like creating constructive conflict
psychological safety getting people to
come up with a wide range of ideas and
then to pick the best the second part is
to give you some of the best case
studies we can find from apple ideo
pixar intel so you can learn from the
best practices and avoid the worst and
then finally we bring you veteran
executives so you can learn from perry
claibon who invented the modern snowshoe
now sort of a master innovation teacher
innovation is something that the
uncertainty can drive fear carl liebert
was ceo of the largest residential real
estate company
change before you have to change once
you get behind it's really difficult to
spend enough money to catch up
sylvia acevedo her last job was ceo of
the girl scouts before that she was a
rocket scientist a tech executive
when people didn't look for somebody
like me i would focus on the skills and
then that allowed me in
finally the remarkable and imaginative
venture capitalist michael dearing you
have to tell a story you have to be
great at making sense of the complex
reality for people
so in leading innovation by bringing you
through a tour of those three things
punctuated by all sorts of different
exercises is to help you understand the
cases and companies you can learn from
the people i hope who can inspire you
and always we go back to
what we think is the best evidence about
what good leaders do and how they design
their teams and their organizations